I'm sure your memory recall capability is very good
and you would have come up with the right answers
for all of these entries. Let me just quickly
summarize what I'm sure that most of you have gotten
already. In all cases except this, where the global
part of the faulting node Ps cache is empty, the
local part of course is going to go up by
one, the global part is going to come down by one.
Only when the global part is empty already, there's no
change. And, in both cases, there's no change to the
balance between L and G on both the node Q,
which is supplying the page X. And the node R
that happens to have the LRU page, because it is
not even part of the action, in terms of the
page fault handling, for these two cases. Now the third
case, is where it is on the disk and therefore
this is immaterial. Right? Because it's not in any
cluster memory right now. It is on the disk, so
it's not applicable. Well, the question is what happens
to the guy that has the globally oldest page. If
it is on the disk and we have to
bring it into the faulting node, then necessarily we have
to make space in the cluster memory as a whole
for this extra page. Because this guy's balance is going to
shift, and I have to throw this global
page somewhere. I am picking this guy as the
replacement candidates, because he has the globally oldest page.
But what is going to happen on this node? Well,
it really depends on whether the LRU page comes from
the global part or the local part. If it comes from the global
part, then there is no change on R, because you're basically throwing
this into the global part, and he's throwing
one of those global pages out onto the
disk, right? If on the other hand, the
global page that I sent over here results in
replacing a local page on node R, because the local page happens to be
the LRU candidate then L goes down by one and G goes up by one. So we had able
to do more community service in this case and in
the last case when it is actively shared, again, even
though we find the missing page in note Q, there's
no change in the balance of L and G because
it is coming from the active part of L, because
it is shared. It indicates if it is shared it
has to be, from the L part of Q. Since
it is actively shared, there's no change in the split
between L and G and of course, this guy has to send one of its global pages
to some other node, because the memory pressure as a whole is increasing on
node P. This guy is going to send it to node R that has the LRU page,
and just like in this case, where I have to make room for the cumulative memory
pressure on the cluster by throwing out a page onto the disk. And similar
to this case, if the candidate replacement page comes from the local part of
R, then it is going to result in the local part shrinking by one
and the global part increasing by one
to accommodate the page that came from here.